it's a pleasure to introduce alex
shapiro who's um
well known to all of you i mean he's a
russell chandler the third
chair and professor in industrial and
systems engineering at georgia tech
too many awards to list but recently i
had a dancing prize
for mathematics uh mathematical
optimization society in siam
and this year was elected to the
national academy of engineering
um so um my pleasure to introduce alex
and
i don't have the title in front of me so
i'll let you i'll let you state it for
us
thank you very much how much time do i
have
you've got 30 minutes yeah 30 minutes
yes
leave a couple minutes of questions if
you can but after such introduction
i'm intimidated
let me open this
and let me do this share screen right
screen
can you see my screen yes looks good
oh okay it's good okay so i can start
yeah
okay so uh let me say first
if you just general words i listened to
many talks here and what
i will talk about probably different
point of view of that
of the stochastic optimization it's
going backwards long way backwards
probably origins
of linear programming with dancing
and all that and
a in my opinion this recent years
it was a very considerable progress in
that
and i would say even different point of
view
on from mainly from computational point
of view what can be solved what cannot
be solved
and how to do that so let me first
state a general setting which is
reasonably simple
right we suppose we have a random
process you can think about that
as the sequence of random vectors this
is your data
and this is just notation for this for
the
history of the process and then you make
decisions
all right in that sense it's very
similar to what
everybody talking about there but
next is this formulation what i say and
it's somewhat
different here right so
again we have objective functions and we
suppose we have
certain period of time over this
horizon and we want to
say minimize it's on average we minimize
the expected
value this is a so what is important
here and it's probably different from
what i heard so far
the first simplifying assumption
simplifying is that the process that
there are distribution
of the process it's supposed to be a
random process
but its distribution is not influenced
by our decision this is very important
assumption
uh why it's like that i will explain in
a moment
yes so in other words the distribution
of this
data process doesn't depend on our
decisions
and i will mainly talk about
linear case so this is what is
here it's basically typically balanced
equations
they're also local constraints in this
formulation there's no clear
separation between state and
state variables and control variables
it's not that important
anymore right so if we take this point
of view
so our policy is just a function of the
information that we have at the time c
now the question is can
this be numerically solved at this point
and this is what i will talk about this
this is where all the progress
is now from this what is written
here is we if we take at this point of
view
we have to solve this infinite
dimensional problem because typically
from modeling point of view
the sequence of random vectors there it
can be even more complex than that
are continuous now
because of that our decisions at every
point of time is a function of the
history
and if we take continual point of view
of continuous distributions
it's infinite dimensional problems so
it's in order to somehow to solve that
even to put in a computer i need to
discretize that
and the huge progress that was in recent
years and all this by using
randomization methods
okay now uh
traditionally if we're going back to
stochastic programming this was
all formulated in terms of scenarios
so if you look all these old books on
stochastic programming
you see this construction of scenarios
three this is what assumed to be
happening in the future so if i go back
to that
right is
can it be really solved this problem
what it means even to solve this problem
right
the complexity of that
is growing fast both
e with respect to dimensions you say the
state
a usually one need to keep track of
state variables
i'll talk about that with dimension of
that of decision variables
and with the number of stages and that
today we have reasonably good
understanding
of complexity of that we say sample
complexity when when
that and the conclusion of that is very
pessimistic
and uh from optimism
from even historical point of view it's
all started with two stages
right even two stage solving two stage
exactly
is probably out of question because one
has to compute
the expectation value which is integral
and his dimension of random growth grows
everyone cannot compute it
accurately so the the future the
progress was made by some optimization
methods
i will not talk about that but a
even linear case when we have this
constraint and we see this typically
balanced type of constraints
the smart coding type of constraints
because we only look at one period
before that and even if our functions
are linear it's linear probably problem
it seems that generically it's
computationally
intractable there are very strong
results about that
saying that and it's understandable why
so nevertheless
uh it's one can you dismiss it that
easily so what can be solved
and why it's i'm talking about
net because if the functions here are
convex with respect to decision
variables
and we have this linear constraints it's
a convex function
so basically if we have finite number of
scenarios scenarios are
possible realizations of our process
right if it is all linear it's possible
and that is constrained here
usually it's simple type of box type of
constraints
uh one thing formulated as a
one large linear programming problem
it's called a deterministic
equivalent of that but the number of
variables and that grows exponentially
both
with dimension of this variation of
variables
and vectors and number of stages and
very quickly become astronomically large
practically impossible to do anything
about that
right so uh the other point
here that probably i should say now a
few words because
it's of course now uh how we know the
distribution of that
even formulation here no there are many
questions about that why we
compute a rhyme we computed on average
state and expected value even if
mathematically i want to formulate that
i need to know the distribution of my
random process
so another program in other directions
became very popular now
so we don't know really the distribution
of that so we take certain family
distribution and we look at min max
problem
so in a static case start a case when we
have the objective function say two
stage when we
from computational point of view that
for a given x
and realization of random data i can
compute the value and probably say sub
gradient or something like that
complexity in optimization classical
optimization
is very very basic it's more important
than differentiability
right so in a static case
classical formulation is okay i will
take the worst possible
case with respect to certain family of
distribution
how to choose this family there's a long
long
discussion i don't have time about that
now
how we can even formulate that in
multi-stage case
is not obvious at all
when we have this when we have the
static case when we have just objective
function there is no dynamics here
right now it's reasonably clear of
course
we take the expectation with respect to
consider this distribution
no and we take maximum of that if
everything is okay
it's reasonably clear what is that
now when we go to a
multi-stage setting it's not clear at
all
what it means and there are quite
non-trivial
technical questions about that i don't
have time to talk about that
one of the possible approaches is about
that
is to assume that there is a reference
measure
and the set of distributions that we're
considering now talk immediately we'll
talk about genomics now is absolutely
continuous with respect
to certain this absolutely certain
reference measure usually it's coming
from the modeling and then you say okay
our modeling is not exact so there's a
certain
set of distributions we can model that
somehow
and uh one is the moment i am talking
about that i can consider the
corresponding function
of that which is defined by this the
worst possible case if i going back to
that
i can look at that i can think about it
as a function of that
and this function has all types of
properties
so a from this point of view it's very
natural to talk about low environments
of that
in other words it's only depend on the
distribution
of our data of that with respect to the
reference measure
and in all these constructions it's
important
okay uh again if we a because we talked
about the sampling
here right if i assume that
it's low invariant it's only depend on
the distribution of that
i can probably construct the sampling
approach of that
i sample i assume that i can sample from
the reference distribution
or in other words when i
observe a random data it's coming from
the true distribution
all right i can probably example that or
i can build a model with that and i can
sample it again from there
and then when i look that's functional i
can
talk about discretization of 8 by
randomization
and then there's a lot of theory about
that
okay now i'd say there's a possible to
show
this this this low invariance
you can look at the law environments
from the point of view of the functional
which is very
natural or from the point of view of the
set of densities that correspond to the
chosen set
and it tends to be this equivalence
between these two
you can go from one to another now and
this is a just
okay now uh one of the classical
examples that i can talk
is the so-called this is a it has many
names
it's called average whether it is
conditional value at risk it has
also long story long a very long history
it was used in economics maybe about 100
years ago in different form
and it's one of the examples
of the very natural examples
of risk functional that one can
construct
somehow this gives penalization on
our higher levels of that if it go
considerably above the average
naturalization so it's very natural to
talk about
this type of risk measures and
again there's a long history about that
i
a this is example of this so-called
lower invariant coherent risk measure
again there's long long history
now let me talk about demonics i don't
have much time
so one for this
one immediately needed question that we
have
how to extend this type of robust
distribution became
recently known under the name robust
distribution
to multi-stage setting to dynamics
so it looks very natural right
one has this objective function know
their constraints
feasibility constraints will optimize it
over policies
right which you which is a certain set
of distributions
of our other process and we take this
type of min max
it turns out that this is not correct
formulation
why it's not correct formulation for
several reasons
it doesn't take this formulation if we
take it looks natural
doesn't take into account the dynamics
of our process
and the original dynamics is conditional
every time we make the decision
it's a condition of what we observed so
far
and this when we take expected value it
has
very natural property of this uh
it has various names that conditionally
if i take conditional expectation
and expectation of that it's become
expectation average of averages is to
total average when we go to more complex
cases like that when we have
distribution robust
or risk averse it doesn't happen anymore
so it's very natural because of that
because of a
i'll start to write now dynamical
equations this is how one can solve this
type of problem
one need to consider this certain type
of nested formulations of that
i try to write it nested formulation so
if this
is a single term right i'll have simply
in other words i'll consider only one
a probability distribution it will be
usually
because of this tower property of
expectation of the usual expectation
but when i consider the maximum of that
i need to take and i take
maximum respect to that inside this
nested formulation which i need to form
for
dynamics of that it's not the same
anymore
i i only even rotate what is called
essential supreme because it's not clear
what it's really supreme of that one
cannot take point by supreme because it
has many problems
measurability and some other problem so
this is not a trigger i don't have time
to go here
this really no trivial technical details
about that
but what is interesting no if you for
example if it is finite of that this is
a reasonably simple thing
or say if you have this discrete
distribution then one can take point
wise maximum of that
what is interesting off there there is
one
measure risk measure a one set of
measures
such that i can write this functional
net form but it's very complicated it's
coming from the nested form
and it will be not the same as this one
even in the simple case that
i will say now when we will have this so
called
this rectangular property of that even
then it's not missing
so when i if i do it like that this
nested formulation i can write it to one
form in this in the previous state was
just
expected value but here it's something
else
which is not observed directly okay
but what we can do we can write
dynamical equations
and a dynamical equation will look like
that
so if i make no assumptions about the
process
i have to keep track of all history of
the process it's useless
because of that i cannot use it for
computations
because then i cannot i have keep the
track of
all history it will be impossible so one
huge simplification movement if i assume
that my set of probability measures has
a rectangular structure
it has different names but it's very
looks very natural
so i can see this my set of my
probabilities has this
uh some type direct struct direct
product structure
so if it is if this a single term if it
is just one
it means that this market this marginal
distribution of my data process
is stochastically independent of each
other
right so here i need to only to model
marginal distributions
of each random vector i don't have to
keep them together
this is huge simplification and of
course the question
is that how is in a practical
application is it okay or not
no it's a long long talk i don't have
time to talk about that sometimes
usually it's markovian structure
sometimes one can reduce to that
but i don't have time to talk about it
so in rectangular case
my dynamical equation simplify
enormously
right so in other words here
i have to deal with only
with the marginal distribution of my
each random vector
and it's the value function if i got is
the value function if i take the current
point respect value function only
depends on state variables
no i didn't say what state variable so
far but in
applications usually it's still
enormous simplification now
yet the two basic questions if i want to
solve that numerically
and this is all about at the end of the
day if it to be useful i
somehow had to solve that one question
is if this has continuous distribution i
had to discretize that
this and we have quite a good idea of
today
what it means uh no because i have to
deal only with the marginal
distributions
i can sample from the marginal
distribution now for a suppose h
i have t stages and i sample from each
one of them say hundred
i have random vector and by using
montenegro technique from each one i
have
sample 100 the total number of scenarios
even by that
if i do it like that grow exponentially
because i have to multiply that
so if i have only even have let's say
three four stages it's already become
astronomical
largely impossible to deal with that but
nevertheless i can look at this value
functions
for of course to go functions the next
questions if i
discretize them right i have to only
deal with the state variables
how can i deal with that i one way of
course i can
also discretize my state space
this is out of questions if dimension of
that is say three or
even three and here we deal with
sometimes of dimension
ten twenty hundred nobody so of course
because of the emotionality problem but
sometimes in some cases
something can be solved this is a point
so the main point
here that the value functions are convex
if i for example consider linear case
and this is extremely important
so uh i will of this
natural idea now is try to approximate
this
value function by cutting planes this is
going a long way
back to in discrete a deterministically
to so-called
kelly algorithms at 60 years ago
right and it's after that was huge
progress and that
in deterministic case probably this
cutting playing type methods based
method based is level method of
nester of numerology but anyway
the idea is the following of that and it
became quite successful
for solving some classes of problems
right so the idea is to approximate
the value function by cutting plane
going backwards and forward
in other words this we
we start from the from this last period
of time
and then we generate certain what is
called trial points when we
add additional cut to our
value function and we know how to do
that
so at every at every iteration we have
lower approximation
of our value function by piecewise are
fine functions which gives support for
them
and we're going backward adding added
more and more cards
even if it is classical this type of
ordering in the forward
after i generate certain approximation
of the value function
i can go forward generating random
random sample of that
and that gives me a point estimate of
the value of the current
this approximation of the policy and
also when i will make
next it the next approximation
this has become known as the gdp
algorithm and it can be extended
to risky worst case quite naturally
and sometimes it works how much time i
have
i i i today for
about seven minutes seven minutes okay
i still have some time so uh if we look
uh so if we look at that
this uh say expected value
what is called risk network right we we
optimize it on average
after we generate random sample form we
sample from each marginal distribution
we have the value current value it's
possible to show that on
average it gives us low bound for the
true
value of that so because of that we can
construct lower bound and
upper bound for the true value of our
problem and see how it converges to each
other
okay a maybe this
very very this important point here
the moment i construct this
approximation
i generate a feasible policy for my
problem with humanness
that has what is called relatively
complicated course
invisibility doesn't happen
because i can go forward generate a
random sample run with some
sample profit called scenario right
and every time i go forward i solve the
corresponding equation this
linear program and let's generate one
possible
solution for this generate sample path
of my my problem
so it can be done for i can do it for
original problem what is called true
problem with continuous distributions
by randomly sampling from continuous
distribution
or i can do it for generated
discretization book
and that gives me ideas how will i
solved the problem
it gave a lawyer i i because of that i
have
a upper bound which is statistical i
simply have
many ig many many sample paths right for
each one of that
i get point and average
it water is sometimes reasonably well
and they have the low bound
okay this is what it's
trying to say now
as i said this uh the
complexity computational complexity of
that growth fast
with generally with a number of stages
and the number of this dimension of the
state
variables how many state variables i
have
why this method sometimes works at all
we don't have very clear understanding
of that
this empirical
explain the experiments that we have
sometimes focus on we will
we sometimes we solve the problem with
very large number of stages 120 stages
something like that with reasonable
variability of the data
right with the state variable say
10 20 something like that
it seems to be the reason that a
from complexity point of view one cannot
really approximate
high dimensional function even convex
uniformly everywhere new number of
cutting planes will start to go
exponentially if you want to
approximate it uniformly but we probably
when we deal with real applications we
probably don't
need to approximate the value functions
everywhere
sometimes it's low dimension probably
this all goes wrong you know much
lower dimension that is dimension of the
state variable sometimes probably
in several places we don't have clear
understanding of that this is one
of the big questions of that
another another problem is that
why we need so many stages
which people some in application people
try to do
i saw that for talk where the people
talk about
ten thousand stages what they can do
with that ten thousand stages
moreover how you can predict your future
that far
in application it's almost always people
use a first stage solution
maybe second for some reasons and then
it's recalculated
as the new information is coming in
so the question in one of the big
questions
how far in the future i should look to
have a reasonable first stage solution
in many cases at least what i know
the problem that problem has periodical
behavior
now let's say with some with the soft we
saw that
on monthly basis something it's a
year has 12 months and that basically
forecasts and it's repeat itself more or
less because
otherwise how one can predict final
future so it turns out
that one one has this type certainly a
periodical behavior of that
it's possible to drastically reduce
number of stages
by using this periodical behavior and
the ideas
here are similar to ideas what people
use of course
in optimal control and mdp but there's
an essential difference
yeah all right first of all we still
even if we first say
period 12 on monthly basis
how to solve them after this and
what i wrote is this somewhat standard
right we have discount factor
and we have certain type of period and
if it repeats itself i written right the
correspondent may know this we
need to make certain assumption the
corresponding type of
genomical equations it's possible to do
in
a risky and a
risk natural case and sometimes it
allows to
drastically reduce the number of the
stages
keeping the essential things of the
problem
one of the reasons why the people use
the many stages is end of horizon effect
because if one use very few stages
the algorithms at the end say use all
your resources
because it doesn't care what happens
afterwards
right because of the deal that people
use many more stages of the effect
this ticket automatically take care
automatically
i suppose i have to finish in a moment
right yes
okay so it's possible to do that
it's i don't have time to talk about
this
this is example of this how we solve
huge problems sometimes
using a low and upper bound upper bound
is computed
by a certain dual
solving certain dual problem and one of
the big big
problems and all that when discount
factors get very close to one
it's well known in that case it's become
more and more difficult
all right so even a and the duplications
that
we deal with that discount factor is
very close to one
it's 0.99 something like that and yet it
was possible to solve with reasonable
accuracy
okay questions oh great um thank you
very much um
i think that we'll have to we're going
to have a break right after the next
speaker
so i think we'll have to defer questions
till then because
otherwise we're going to lose our uh our
break um
but i'm sure there'll be lots of
questions that i especially yeah i'd
like to see another talk on the
examples but again again thank you very
much